says uh couldn't fly the meter but
here's four bucks
the bad news is we can't get you in
front of a judge until Monday morning
oh uh officer that's just impossible no
we need to be in LA tomorrow for a
wedding you stole a police car we didn't
steal anything
um we found it if anything would deserve
a reward or something like a trophy not
to mention it's pathetic mmm those
places are filthy yeah and the worst
part is that little girl grinding and
dry humping the stage up there that's
somebody's daughter daughter up there I
was just gonna say that see hey what's
all that the High Roller Packers it's
what you guys ordered I have coffee mugs
why do you have baseball caps huh and
fancy calendars all with pictures of Stu
and Jade drink gee she's beautiful man
clean very tight it's like that but
that's because she had a baby there that
explains the baby
Oh Carlos Carlos
oh holy where are we oh my god Alan your
head no your head we have no idea where
even is so what Alan well I was just
gonna say I got this strange email the
other day I wasn't sure what it meant
but now I think it might be from chow
fatty it feels good to be out close by
tell no one I'll be in touch ciao
this says chow how did you not know this
was from chow at the time I thought it
was Chow like goodbye
you know like child Riva dirge a Sbarro
Papa getting back here you got a puss
no I chin the way back thank you
oh my god oh my god you just nailed the
baby that glass is okay your glasses are
fine dick gets apart so close yeah
what's wrong
shouldn't be here why is that Alan I'm
not supposed to be within 200 feet of a
school
what or chuck-e-cheese
Oh
my work through my bad ah you guys might
not know this but I consider myself a
bit of a loner I tend to think of myself
as a one-man Wolf Pack but when my
sister brought Doug home I knew he was
one of my own and my Wolf Pack it grew
by one so were there two of it there
were two of us in the Wolf Pack
I was alone first in the pack and then
Doug joined in later and six months ago
when Doug introduced me to you guys I
thought wait a second could it be and
now I know for sure I just added two
more guys to my wolf pack all right four
of us wolves
running around the desert together in
Las Vegas looking for strippers and
cocaine
the health of your gun to even have been
the pinion on what I've been doing with
the head of yo one